[Music]
look
it's no secret that right now north
american counter-strike is
well a little worse for wear between
covid ousting all of our orgs valorance
snagging our up-and-comers
and the fact that our last truly
consistent roster was a bunch of
bison-worshipping brazilians it is
starting to seem as if
real farm-raised locally sourced
counter-strike is
at least for now dead there's so little
n a teams now
like n a as a whole is not popular at
all
i mean you have what do you have you
have eg
you have complexity you have liquid
that's it like and then the rest is just
like eu
you know and they just died in in cs
hard every star assailant worth their
salt is shipping off to europe
and those who couldn't make the cut are
cashing in condom guy
for the next glitch pop set hell even
our most
iconic streamers are spending several
days a week
teaching league players how to run a
[ __ ] default
guys they're rushing b every round
they're just rushing
why are you playing three [ __ ] ay
oh wow look there's four or five
here sure the casual player base is
booming
but it is starting to feel as if there
are fewer and fewer places where
die hard tryhards can take root and grow
bastions or casuals and competitors
alike can come together
enliven nacs and dare i say
save it once and for all okay well to be
fair there is one place
but the guy who runs it spends way too
much time talking about dicks
colin nice cup thanks for the five ten
gifted you sexy [ __ ] and the five month
reese of great food year [ __ ]
today we're simping the big bearded
beauty that is
eric flom flom a professional player
turned content creator whose unwavering
love for counter-strike has cemented him
as not only his region's last great
dedicated cs streamer
but an impromptu godfather of sorts
let's go bro you better hurry the [ __ ]
up
too much talking too much talking i'm
shooting his leg i'm shooting his legs
this is how myth it gets subs
see it isn't just that flom is
charismatic it's that he's
committed he has stuck with cs through
thick and thin
and the more that other games have
started to captivate his region's
interest
the more his refusal to switch games has
piqued the interest of like-minded cs
lovers
everything that he does he's trying to
do it for the nac
and he's just trying to keep the na
dream alive you know so what drove flom
to abandon a career in politics to cap
heads for a living
and what do coffee mugs with five gifted
printed on the side
shoes on heads and having a nice [ __ ]
have to do with counter strike
that's where it all goes
[Applause]
okay so if you are in need of a crash
course on the flom daddy
i'm just the guy to give it to you he's
a full-time streamer
self-sufficient org co-owner and an
occasionally nutty opera who despite
looking about 20 years older than he
actually is
isn't nearly as washed as you might
think all right bro here's the plan
you're gonna run out i'm gonna bait you
and i'm gonna kill all of them go
go go go
never seen you lose
you're so good told you what would
happen
and i [ __ ] delivered did i not his
interests include
[ __ ] stomping silvers as casually as if
it were his day job
because well it is
terrorists yup clip it and ship it
being mercilessly bullied by his chat
mom why do you look like a dwarf guys i
have feelings i'm a person
hey and getting absolutely farmed
by yours truly
he [ __ ] kills me are you [ __ ]
my ass raw with no lube
sandbag sandbag damn he's better than
him sorry
i didn't quite catch that i'm just i'm
i'm what
damn he's better than him well he didn't
quite say it but uh
we take those dmitry i'll actually ask
something on twitter right now what the
hell did you just blow me up in
let me respond with sucks
just suck anyway so where did flom come
from
and how did his stream become the place
to be if you're a part of that
sorry god forsaken lot known as north
american counter-strike fans
well in spite of looking like a homeless
viking
flam isn't actually your typical djen
gamer type in fact once upon a time
this smart straight-laced son of a
university professor
had his sights set on a career in
politics
it was mostly out of necessity it wasn't
really something that i was ever
passionate about it was just very easy
to me
i just did what had to be done to get my
parents off my back
so i could focus on counter-strike which
is what i really cared about
now as for his professional cs go career
it was
sweet but short-lived he spent two years
bouncing around amateur rosters before
briefly signing with luminosity in
february of 2015.
this is perfect for luminosity and
they're gonna be able to catch apex off
guard
there you go the aggressive push but rpk
waiting for lex with that max 10 he's
gonna pick up the first but flom is
wreaking havoc right now at a pit
in existence and maniac are the last two
guys alive if you're strictly just
looking at when i was a paid
professional in luminosity as my
professional career
i was good at the right time and then
i was really bad at a very important
time but also our team was a cluster
unfortunately as most of you are
probably aware nacs has
always had a reputation for being a bit
of a [ __ ] show
flum realized early on that if he
couldn't find a roster with whom he
could grow
flourish and just compete seriously
it was probably better to just not
compete at all i've had
offers from other teams to like play in
the pro division if i wanted
um the answer is i don't want to sit
here and
i don't i don't want to join a team i
don't really
i want them to be good yeah but i also
want a team that's going to stick
together for a while so
not really i'm not trying to like just
force myself
i wanted to make sure to play right away
you know what i mean the thing is
flom had a back-up plan you see he'd
fancied himself something of an
entertainer for quite some time
and was actually one of his region's
first real
personalities to play counter-strike on
twitch so
like several of north america's usual
suspects
flahm went whole hog into streaming i
wanna stream i want to be involved with
counter-strike in some way like that was
just what i was going to do there wasn't
another option even in my mind
that was all i wanted whatever i had to
do to make that happen i was going to
make it happen
now keep in mind this was back when cs
go actually had a fairly
massive twitch following battle royales
were a long ways away
and it made sense to full send your way
into valve's edgy
explosive esports-centric shooter and
that is exactly
what our boy did yes patience boys
slowly but surely flam began to
cultivate a community of fans
around his irreverent authentic
cs with the boys type playstyle
and persona whether he was raising
awareness for his
all too incurable whiffington's disease
or sharing his thoughts on various
aspects of the meta
how's the tech9 jumping i don't know man
i'm not really too worried about that
flam eventually began to cement himself
as both a staple source of entertainment
and an unofficial figurehead of sorts
come here you crouch
yeah and then you came right here
whoa oh my god
he even became the co-owner of mythic an
org which focuses on the development of
up-and-coming talent
and kicked off his very own pub league
originally me and adren were supposed to
be faces of a different hub
and face it just said well this is dumb
you guys should just have your own
and we're like sure maybe
like because you know at that time
mythic was just a roster that i put
together and gave us a name
i just wanted to see something and
create something cool and it attached me
and it and it really grounded me in the
community
and just i don't know it made me care
more the issue of course
is that eventually streaming
counter-strike
became less and less popular on twitch
but
even as brs began to take off a genre in
which flam did dabble in from time to
time
he never abandoned his roots
and then in the spring of 2020 we saw
the release of the real
so-called counter-strike killer
valorant within no time virtually all of
north america's
biggest counter-strike creators were
orchestrating either
partial or full-time switches to riot's
shiny new shooter flom checked it out
too of course and since he was given the
chance to drop
beta keys his stream actually grew
significantly
i think what valor did is when i had
those drops
my name was now not only something that
you'd heard before but you'd
you see the top of a directory
consistently for a while
so i think undeniably valor grew my
audience i also think
it it brought a lot of people in that
had previously heard of me
knew roughly who i was but i actually
took the you know the first dive into my
stream
what set flum apart was that once the
hype surrounding the beta had subsided
he was pretty much the only big north
american streamer to go
back to counter-strike full-time but
what's really crazy
is that his newly increased viewership
came with him
the beautiful thing about flom's journey
is that he found success
by remaining a stalwart supporter of the
game
region and all-around culture in which
he was raised
and today his stream stands as
essentially the last
refuge of scrubby north american
counter-strike stands
whether he's offering deep analytical
breakdowns during his watch parties
wait
wait his face [ __ ] or bringing together
community figures competitors
and famous music producers and watching
as they engage
in some very stupid [ __ ] okay
yes yes yes
flom has managed to turn his stream into
this kind of
cs go variety show a haven where
anyone who adores this awesome outdated
masterpiece of a shooter
can connect with others just like them i
want to stream and have a good time with
my community
and that's like the number one thing
that i prioritize over anything else
now some may look at flam and see a
bearded retiree with a shoe on his head
a
sea of sub-par content and a semi-decent
public
what i see is a hero a guy who's
fighting to keep
the game that he loves alive in a region
in which it's pretty much
always struggled to gain recognition i
do try to push people
to stream more even if they are a
professional player because
na needs kind of somebody that is just
there that they can
you know if they want to watch them cs
and they want to see a north american
player they have somebody and he's come
a long way because of it
now i have my own skin
and a name trainer bro with my logo in
it and everything
that's so crazy to me you know what i
mean flum may not be
the savior that north american
counter-strike asked for
he may not even be the one it deserved
but he sure as [ __ ]
the one it needed you know bringing
brings new players from
the community to you know kind of have
an opportunity to play
with a player like flom and you know
kind of have that interaction from
you know a professional level to you
know a casual level
um i think he plays a big part in it and
i think we should be grateful to have
him
so for once on behalf of a community for
whom you have done
so much let me be the one to say
nice bro dude i'm gonna crack up
no flop is hair like mine actually he
kind of has like the same kind of like
we're kind of like hair bros kind of
he has the same like kind of like we
both look like that dude from the
in-game model in cs the professor guy
with the glasses the beard and the
the the hair yes yes okay
we both run that guy in game too